step on the gas on step ahead that is
huge it's looking right hey folks said
Ford and Mark Wilson here we just got
hands-on with Final Fantasy 15 episode 2
sky demo the one that we have already
seen before but no one's actually played
that's right we've laid it yeah this is
a demo that's coming out with Final
Fantasy type-0 again pre-order that game
or you buy that game you will get it
with that at least while stock last say
Square Enix well in the demo video that
everyone has seen on YouTube it's quite
a long time it's like 45 minutes it paid
the same bit except up to where we see
the bear moth in the demo we play beyond
that we got to fight it as well we did
five behave of but not just that we
fought like the run-of-the-mill enemies
of disguise as well and the main thing
is that the the combat feels a bit more
hack and slash a little bit more fluid a
bit more active yeah which is quite I
mean look it's super different it's a
really different game I mean like so
it's you know this guy the way it's an
open-world game the big map to explore
and their enemies roaming around it
they're not random battles so you will
see them you can avoid them yeah that's
cool when you get into battle there's no
it doesn't like zoom out to about memory
it's fluid it goes straight from from
roaming into fighting in fact you can
still pull out your sword and swipe just
as your ambling around this jump you can
jump
forget about goal defenses yes you
believe it just not just jump but you
can like leap okay the things as well
yes dramatically and in battle though
you can you can leap in battle and leap
up into the air the assault right there
and that's probably the main point of
how the actual fighting takes place
right so instead of saying I want to do
attack or magic or this or this instead
you have all of your physical attacks
mapped to the square button and it's how
you use the square button how you hit it
hold it tap it
anything jump and hit that makes the
different acts happen yeah it's like a
weird amalgamation of a sort of slightly
hack-and-slash feel and there is real
time and you have to dodge and then you
have to carry but at the same time
you're not executing what I'd call super
fast combos now instead you're sort of
tapping in the commands with square and
then waiting from the play
and then following it up following
through with more commands so it's a
weird mix between the two but it does
work and it's still targeted as well
it's not just like just hurl your sword
in every direction you still you're
targeting with armed ones all right yeah
okay so targeting with r1 defending with
l1 that's right
so defending is what uses up your MP so
dessert oh no you're right you're right
is defending you so defending usurp my
MP so distorting and then the other
thing that use your MP for our further
the more powerful attacks Maps our
triangle yeah that's right so I mean we
didn't see much in the way of sort of
big magic stuff from the demo but what
we did we did have were sub special
attacks map to the physical weapons like
they get swords and axes and things and
this is one of the the sort of key
differences between Final Fantasy 15 and
the other final fantasies and it's
battle system is that the moves that you
have are dependent on the weapons you're
carrying so you carry multiple weapons
five demo five at any one time yeah and
those are what your combos are based on
and obviously you can get different
weapons better weapons and level them up
and all that sort of stuff
so each of the five different attacks
are based on how how you go about your
fight so that up try that Square will
always begin with the same swipe like a
flurry the other thing and at the
beginning of our demo we had quite a
lightweight sword attached that so it's
a very quick but not particularly
powerful it's exactly and then just to
switch things up we ended up using a
weapon called the spy hander which was
this an almost aggressive every now I
just had a hard neighbour remember I'm
gonna remember that one so had this like
axe cross mace cross sword kind of vibe
it was just like a giant blade on a
stick and much heavier yes it took
longer to yeah but you could still do
the flurry with it but you end up taking
you had a more you know more reach at
one point we hit like three enemies at
once yes just in the flurry just like
the targeting but then you can also
change it up to maybe you want it to be
like a spear
yes the poking spear the point is that's
what I called it but then we use the
pokey spear for the dive attack so it's
like the jump and jump and then then
attack yeah
it's really cool how you can do that I'm
at the lacrosse stick so I guess maybe
there's going to be some advantages of
changing up which kind of weapons you
use for different kinds of attacks if
you get the opportunity to build all the
way through your
follow-ups where we actually did the
most damage apart from the MP skills
mapped to triangle were with accountants
they were really strong yeah they're
quite tricky to pull off of me and so
the counter system in this there it is
based upon like timing basically so what
you do is you hold down the our one
button is put into your defender sense
yet and then basically when the enemy
comes in to attack some colored lines
flash up on the screen yeah
at that moment yet you have to push
square at the right time that launches a
counter and then you can follow up with
the attack again with a massive big tons
of damage under damage yeah it's very
cool but tricky to do you have to
practice and get the timing right and
the other thing that's definitely worth
mentioning yes the the the MP stuff with
dodging dodging does use up MPs you call
a lot it's not like when you play
something like you know sort of Delma
cry or bayonetta where you're easily
mostly dodging cuz that's the art the
gameplay in this you have to think yeah
otherwise if you run out of MP you're
screwed so you can't do anything else
yeah and one of the better ways to
recover MP and HP and basically just
sort of take a breather from the battle
was the warp system yeah so often around
areas that you'd be taking place in
these these battles you have maybe a
tower off in the distance or maybe a
hybrid wall or anything really and
you'll see a targeting reticule cap up
on it saying warp and you just trigger
that with the X button you kind of a
shoot over to it jab your sword in it
and kind of hang there you just kind of
go like see you ladies and all your
buddies do all the work yeah they're all
getting stabbed in whatever annual arms
hanging out guys I'm just recovering my
own baby yeah which you know is again
that's worth pointing out is a
progenitor that you regenerate your
health and MP as you're walking around
and in battle yeah
however the crux of this is once your
your em your HP is down to zero yeah and
you get sort of knocked out yeah any
further damage you take from that point
will decrease the overall length of your
HP bar and he'll you take a potion or
get here yield that back up as well yeah
which can happen quite quickly as we
learned to our detriment yes over and
over so the five the final thing that we
did in the demo was fight this this big
monster called the eBay oh yes
and it was incredibly difficult than I
had you know I guess you know if we were
going around you could level up a bit
more but it was it was really difficult
yeah yeah big poor attack that basically
you could just pummel and pummel and
pummel and and we suffered we suffered
heavily you suffered heavily yeah right
so it was a lot of warping out warping
back in and when we walk back in with an
attack yes yeah which was quite useful
so you can sort of warp out turn around
jab run away again which was maybe a
viable technique we don't really know
yeah but the how did it remind you of
other Final Fantasy specifically I mean
it's really you know if you've played
other Final Fantasy games this one is
going to come as a bit of a bit of a
shock it is quite different there's a
lot of Kingdom Hearts in there I think
you sure you know there's none of the
turn-based stuff so you know if you play
7a even 13 you know that they all have
that element of entering a lot of
commands like that is not there I think
the closest thing you get to the turn
base is waiting for your MP to
regenerate yeah so that you can perform
another one of them the more powerful
attacks that's probably the closest it's
going to come to that in terms of the
style I got quite a lot of crisis core
vibes yeah because it's it's sort of
circling your opponent keeping moving
moving moving all the time and you can
attack at any point it's not exactly the
same but it's probably the closest
approximation I can think of yeah and
then lastly as well you're only
controlling your character not that's
right you're not controlling multiple
characters they sort of go off and do
their own thing they'll help you with
Celtx day they help you attacks and
they'll hear you they will yeah and it's
in your benefit of course to try and
heal them when they when they drop but
if they're still in danger they won't
recover on their own example so if
they're still being hounded by multiple
enemies it's going to be very difficult
to recover them yeah I mean it's really
different but I think you know you need
to try out the demo if you can get hands
on Final Fantasy type-0 and see what you
think I'm will be interested hear what
you think so that was the fighting
system in Final Fantasy 15 but there was
loads of other really really cool stuff
that we saw in the demo as well that you
should totally check out for example
like random encounters with chocobos ah
the music playing in the chocoberry ROG
the little truck around the back of the
chocobo ranch there has a nod to maybe
Final Fantasy 7 it was pretty cool it
was soon yeah but there's more coming
out from packs right yeah so the guys in
the u.s. they're they're checking out
at PAX they're going to talk to you more
about the environment at large and how
beautiful this game looks - I can't I
really can't wait
awesome so guys for everything else
around Final Fantasy 15 make sure you
stay tuned to games.com
you